hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here to examine
jiu-jitsu kaisen's death painting arc
which had significantly less painting
than i'll say i anticipated
plenty of death though so there is that
and for plenty more please do remember
to press that their subscribe button for
the new world review which will result
in consistent injections of
curse-related goodness uploaded straight
into your youtube feed oh and just a
minor spoiler warning i've been told
that i'm getting pretty extraordinarily
close to where the anime is
and that this current arc might not be
done by the time this video comes out
so venture forward at your own risk but
the premise of the death painting arc is
pretty intriguing it very much starts
out with a puzzling murder mystery
premise before promptly diving deeply
into fushiguro as well as setting up
what looks to be a pretty fun intriguing
future villain but in regards to
fushiguro it was made pretty obvious
from the get-go that we would be using
him as a standout figure akitami made
some very deliberate choices with both
yuji and kiwisaki during the stark where
they were generally paired together and
not only that but in the very beginning
they were also portrayed as pretty much
the same character in some comical
scenes with the same fun reactions and
everything and whilst yuji has always
been on more or less of a similar
wavelength to kugasaki this time the two
of them were completely in sync and the
reason why that was done was an active
effort to make fushiguro stand out from
the very
beginning a character like kim can be
quite hard to handle because of his
quiet and reserved nature but i think
akatami found a pretty brilliant
solution to that here
very much artificially making fushigura
stand out by having yuji and kukisaki
blend in together and really if you just
sat down and started reading this arc
without any context to juditsukai so
whatsoever you would probably think that
fushiguro was the main protagonist
of course the setting being his old
junior high and the exploration with his
sister would also contribute to that all
of which was quite enjoyable any
opportunity to expand
on him is very welcome and i did like
that nephit was made to explore his
self-sacrificial nature and there's one
quote that really hit me during the sarc
which came from a fly-looking casual
gojo
stating that being introduced sorcerer
is an individual sport no matter how
many allies you have around you you'll
always die alone which is fascinating
because as much as this was all about
fushiguro it definitely called me right
back to the very first chapter and the
words of yuji's grandfather which was a
warning to you know
not do that he very strictly said do not
die alone so what does yuji do after
that well he chooses the one profession
where dying alone is industry standard
practice
and it also brings back echoes of the
principal's initial words that no
sorcerer dies without regret so casual
fly f gojo here provided a nice hit of
morbidity and a reminder of exactly what
we're up against here it's actually been
so long that i have kind of forgotten
that the entire plan fuji was to be
executed and that's not really
commensurate with the events that we've
been through all about getting stronger
saving people and yes making the best of
friends and there's a nice extra hit of
morbidity as well because this doesn't
just apply to youtube but to all of our
students who on their multiple parts are
apparently all heading towards the same
sort of tragic end with that said in for
shigeru's case these words were quite
enlightening and led
seeing a side of him that i didn't
really think existed sort of
in a release of restraint and from there
we were treated to all sorts of fun art
of him smiling and laughing albeit in a
very
very twisted manner but i do like the
overall message that was presented here
which was give it your all it's okay to
be selfish
because you will almost never hear that
in a shorter manga as they are usually
about promoting selflessness above all
else and also it would seem that
fushiguro has
a thing i want to call it a domain but
that's not what he called it i think it
was an area
expansion i believe culminating in a
chimera shadow garden i'm going to
assume it's either like a mini domain or
an incomplete domain which i do think
fujikura quite literally states but
these are always fascinating because
they give us a glimpse of core character
a morphing shadow garden at once ornate
beautiful
versatile and terrifying and also the
idea is that shadows tend to be very
sneaky background features so all of
this is pretty perfectly for girl and i
would love to see the complete version
and i would also go into fushkar's
sister smiki but i really don't know how
much more there is to say
right now it's nice to have another
reference to her because
i think when we first saw her way back
when it was just a weird out-of-contact
shot but i guess it's good to know that
there's something in the background
motivating fushiguro along with the
whole xenon family thing but this does
feel like a setup for a later story to
play out so
i'll talk about it then not to be
neglected during the sack yuji and
kogisaki end up forming a pretty
fearsome duo and actually having stated
that the focus of this arc was very
fushiguro-centric it's these two who
receive the grand action and even
emotional climax come to think of it in
regards to the latter there's this
really striking set of four pages
towards the end of the arc where
akhitami draws a conversation between
yuji and kugasaki where we spend one
page looking at one character from the
exact same camera angle four different
times then we do the same with the other
character
then we flip back and so on in these
pages aesthetically are quite
unremarkable they're so unremarkable
that they are indeed remarkable they're
very flat the panel sizes are all
uniform and it really does go against
the core principles of manga page layout
but the real beauty of what akatami does
with these four pages
is remove all unnecessary visual flair
so that we are forced to focus on the
subtle differences of expression within
the characters going through each of
their series of panels is an emotional
journey of two characters coming to
terms with what they've done in their
different ways and a very minor thing
that does actually help is that even
though it's a static shot of each
character the forest background actually
changes with each panel which is kind of
trippy and really does make me feel like
i'm cutting to a completely new
character with each emotional shift so
it's stupidly subtle but also
very very effective and it's something
that gives me a lot of trust in
akutami's creative decision making i've
brought this up before but i'm really
starting to believe that akatami's
greatest strength as an author is
knowing what not to draw like in this
specific arc as well there's a whole
series of panels in fushigoro's mind
which are just
words featuring the kind words of samiki
backed by pristine flat white whilst
fushigoro's pessimistic thoughts are
played against this despairful flat
black i think that most mangaka would be
hesitant to do something like this
because manga is supposed to be
primarily a visual medium especially
mangaka with akutami's level of skill
and yet the restraint he shows where it
really matters is quite enlightening
because the kind of stuff that he draws
or
even types in in text during these
moments can be achieved by
literally any artist however very few of
them could use these simple choices as
effectively back to eugene kugisaki
though in fact specifically
kuisaki this time she got some fantastic
moments to shine i love seeing her in
action even if she is slightly
terrifying kugisaki just fights with
such a sinister smile it's almost
sadistic really and hey she got to
perform a black flash alongside yuji
which was pretty damn cool
who speaking of was thrown into another
moral quandary during the sark for
reasons i haven't touched on yet our
main antagonists were not cursed spirits
or at least they weren't
fully cursed spirits in fact they were
even capable of emotion which means that
yuji needed to make a serious decision
over whether or not to actually kill his
opponent which he eventually did but he
also apologized beforehand
and the whole situation was just tragedy
as per usual it did show some very solid
growth though because this is not the
first time that yuji has been forced to
kill and i suppose that his resolve has
now been far more steadied which leads
us to esso and ketchizu one of which
gave me some pretty distinct jojo vibes
for obvious reasons and here's the thing
as much as i felt for yuji and kogisaki
needing to kill them i also felt really
bad that these two needed to die in the
first place i mean sure they're
antagonists but they have such a twisted
creation story and this whole brotherly
bond going on that it was
definitely just very very sad that story
was quite fascinating though because it
introduced us to sorcery of the past
with the specific figure of nori
toshikamo being flagged aka the most
evilest
of sorcerer dudes in history which was
fun because i thought that the most evil
sorcerer in history would have been
tsukuna so
interesting to know also though isn't
noritoshikamo like the exact same name
as the guy from kyoto who we fought
against in the last arc and if so
why would you name your child after the
most evil sorcerer to have ever existed
especially if it is a stain on your
family name
it's like having harry potter name his
child voldemort why
why why would why why in any case nori
toshikamo the uh the much older one
is responsible for a cursed womb
abomination which is a concept that i'm
very glad we're bringing back
and i think the implication is that he
created nine death paintings the only
ones we've seen thus far being one to
three whatever the case
i do like history diving into stuff like
this that happened hundreds or perhaps
even thousands of years ago makes the
world feel
a lot easier to be immersed in rather
than examining a more superficial modern
day story with no depth to be exported
but in the end two of our three
paintings fall
leaving choso i think his name is who i
imagine will be rather upset with our
first years upon eventually meeting them
you can definitely tell that he was the
one intended to be a more long-term
character though because his design was
on a completely different level to the
other brothers who more or less looked
like monsters of the week they're quite
complicated though mostly because of
this whole being partly human thing it
really muddies the waters even more in
regards to the whole
r curses human discussion because they
definitely are but they're also
definitely not so where do they fit in
in any given ideology like i have a hard
time believing that cyclops spirit dude
what's his name it's like the opposite
of gojo
jogo that's it i have a hard time
believing that he would be so accepting
of them into his
neo-human world but then again old form
humans probably wouldn't be too quick to
accept them either
or would they i mean probably not but
really even our grand good guys in this
world
invoke dark curse powers so what would
be the difference in accepting someone
into society who was partially a cursed
spirit in any case those questions don't
need to be answered right now and this
harkens with a
surprisingly delightful chapter
featuring a girl that likes yuji just
rocking up out of nowhere and that was
very cute extremely out of place i don't
know why we're exploring this
just yet but it was also a really nice
break from the flood of morbidity being
thrown our way almost like a reminder of
the sort of thing that we're fighting
for because as much as the negativity of
humans have resulted in these curses
there's also plenty of good things
happening in the world of course what i
fear most however is that this
delightful innocent girl yuko
i think and i fear that she is going to
be used for some sort of major
major tragedy in the future sort of like
jinpei's mother or even better
jinpe himself she's just too likable too
normal and
as such this series is a very very
dangerous place for
yuko to be inhabiting that's not quite
it though because we did have some very
relevant revelations here as well which
is that yuji fujiguro kugisaki maki
and the bestest of the boys panda have
all been recommended for a promotion to
grade
1 sorcerers which is very cool but feels
very quick
just flying straight to the top of the
hierarchy like that i mean not the very
top there are grades above it i imagine
like special grades semi special grade
etc but still that's pretty wild
especially since as far as i can recall
yuji is completely
unranked and was anonymity a grade one
sorcerer so yeah that's pretty insanely
panda on the other hand is completely
deserving of such an accolade in fact i
think he should be a special grade
because he's a very special boy
so really what we appear to have
accomplished with the whole death
painting shenanigan re is a rather
successful bridging arc it was a nice
break from the chaotic character
juggling events of the kyoto goodwill
event arc and it was really good to
finally get back to this basic trio
dynamic of yuji fushiguru and kugisaki
something that we really haven't had
since the very beginning of the series
and overall it was just a more basic
uncomplicated character growth story
whilst also doing some work to seed
future stories
and very well done arc and the only
thing left to say is that i want more so
that pretty much does it for this blind
review of jutsukai sen's death
painting arc and what do you guys think
please to leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
jujutsu sorcery then please do check out
some of my other videos and even
subscribe to the channel for very maybe
regular jujutsu kaiser morbidity
delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time